Bitte schön.
Ja, guten Tag.
Herr Doktor.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Mehtap Mert.
Seit fast drei Jahren wohne ich mit meiner Kinder in Deutschland.
Vor 18 Jahren habe ich mein Studium in der Türkei absolviert.
Und in der Türkei habe ich fünfzehn Jahre lang als Erstin in verschiedenen Abteilungen gearbeitet.
Ich habe keine Facharzt-Weiterbildung.
Seit zweieinhalb Jahren lerne ich Deutsch.
Und am 20.Achte lege ich Fachprachprüfung beim Preiburg-Arzt-Echame ab.
Das war ein Vorgespräch mit dem Ärztlichen Direktor.
Jetzt kommen Sie zu den Patienten, die im Raum das nicht zu erzählen.
Okay.
Darf ich anfangen?
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Mehtap Mert.
Heute bin ich auf dieser Station als Assisterin Erstin tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich bin sehr einsverstanden.
Okay. So als benötige ich ein paar Ihre persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Otto Schilly.
Also Schilly ist der Nachname.
Otto ist der Vorname.
Otto mit WT.
Könnten Sie bitte langsam Ihre Nachname stabilen?
Ja, gerne. Das schreibt sich mit S-C-H-I-Doppel-L-Y.
Schilly.
Okay.
Doppel-L-Y.
Richtig.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,80 m.
Und wiege ich um die 97, 98 kg?
98 kg.
Okay. Habt ihr einen Haushalts- oder Haushalts-Sin?
Ja, mein Haushalts-Sin ist Dr. Müller.
Dr. Müller.
Herr Dr. Müller, oder?
Ja, genau.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich komme wegen Schmerzen zu Ihnen.
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Die sind unten im Bauch bei mir.
Da sind Bauchkrämpfe, die ich habe.
Ich habe sie im Bauch auf der linken Seite.
Die werden mal mehr, mal weniger.
Aber die habe ich seit gestern Abend.
Nur seit gestern Abend?
Ja.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, richtig.
Früher hatten Sie auch ähnliche Schmerzen?
Ja, ich hatte solche Schmerzen schon mal.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich ähnliche Schmerzen.
Aber diese Schmerzen sind stärker.
Vor zwei Jahren hatten Sie ähnliche Schmerzen?
Ja, das dauerte nur zwei Tage.
Und dann ging es wieder von alleine weg.
Und dann war lange nichts mehr.
Und jetzt habe ich starke Schmerzen.
Okay.
Und dann war es noch nicht mehr.
Jetzt sind auch starke Schmerzen seit gestern.
Und könnt uns bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich meine, drückend, dumm, oder?
Ja, das sind so krampfartige Schmerzen, würde ich sagen.
Da kampf sich mein Darm zusammen.
Krampfartige und?
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Ich meine,
wobei eins ist sehr leicht und zehn ist unerträglich.
Also wenn mal so so Krämpfe kommen, dann ist es schon,
ich sage, sieben bis acht, kann man schon sagen.
Okay.
Bei Krämpfen, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Begleitsthymptomen?
Also ich habe jetzt auch einmal erbrochen, wo die Schmerzen ganz stark waren.
Das war nur einmal.
Dann soll ich vielleicht erwähnen, also ich hatte letzte Woche,
da muss ich sagen, habe ich auch Schwierigkeiten mit dem Stuhlgang gehabt.
Aber auch mal Blut dabei gewesen, aber das war nur einmal.
Beim Stuhlgang Blut, oder?
Ja, richtig, ja.
Okay.
Und beim Erbrechen gibt es auch Blut?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Und wann war diese Beschwerden beim Stuhlgang mit Blutung?
Vor einem Woche.
Das war vor einer Woche, aber ich habe immer wieder so Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Also mal habe ich längere Zeit kein Stuhlgang, dann nehme ich mal was ein,
dann habe ich Durchfall auch wieder.
Also das ist bei mir schon seit längerer Zeit ein Problem mit dem Stuhlgang.
Was meinen Sie mit längeren Seiten?
Ein paar Monate, glaube ich.
Dann nehme ich auch manchmal Abführmittel und dann denke ich mal,
dass vielleicht durch den Durchfall auch Blut gekommen ist,
aber war nur einmal, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Müssen Sie immer Abführmittel benutzen?
Oder das ist wie zum Beispiel drei Tage Verstopfung,
dann ist das Verstopfung, dann ist es ein Zeit lang mal gar nichts,
dann habe ich wieder Verstopfung und dann Durchfall.
Also sehr unregelmäßig kann man sagen.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen nur im linken Unterbauch?
Ja, auch, ja, Mitte und Unterbauch.
Ohne Ausstrahlung, oder?
Die sind nur im Bauch, ja, die strahlen nicht woanders hinaus.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Okay.
Was haben Sie gestern gegessen oder dagegen nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich meine gegen Schmerzen?
Ich habe Schmerzen im Eboprofen eingenommen, ja.
Wie viele Milligramm und wie viele Milligramm?
Das sind, ich glaube 400 Milligramm, die ich zu Hause habe.
Die habe ich eigentlich nicht mehr.
Hat geholfen ein bisschen, dann, was war wie mit dem Schmerz?
Das ist ein Problem, das ich habe.
Ich habe mich zu Hause geholfen, die habe ich eigentlich nicht mehr.
Hat geholfen ein bisschen, dann, was war wieder schlechter?
Also das hat nicht durchgehend geholfen.
Okay.
Gestern haben Sie nur einmal eingenommen, oder?
Ja, heute Morgen aber auch nochmal.
Okay, und heute noch mal.
Und nur ein bisschen Verbesserung.
Nur bisschen, ja.
Und haben Sie Vererträglichkeit?
Was meinen Sie genau, Frau Doktor?
Ich meine, haben Sie Intoleranz, zum Beispiel Laktosintoleranz oder unverträgliche Asthka?
Ah, bisher war da nichts bekannt, nein.
Beim Stuhlgang und beim Erbrechen.
Ist das die frische Blut, hellrot oder beim Stuhlgang?
War das Terrestyl oder braune farbliche Stuhlgang?
Also, erbrechen war nur einmal, Frau Doktor,
und da war auch kein Blut dabei.
Ach, sorry, sorry, ja.
Und mit dem Stuhlgang, das war nur einmal, aber das war wenig
und war eher so dunkles Blut, glaube ich.
Also es war so älteres Blut, fand ich.
Okay.
War nicht frisch.
Okay, nicht hellrot.
War nur einmal.
Okay.
War nur einmal, nicht mehrfach.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Also, ich habe gemessen, heute Morgen war so 37,8.
37,8.
Ein bisschen erhöht.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Nicht so hoch.
Und nur einmal haben Sie gemessen.
Also heute gemessen, gestern habe ich nicht gemessen,
heute habe ich...
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Überkeit?
Also, wie gesagt, nur wenn ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich
übelkeit, und dann musste ich einmal erbrechen,
als die Schmerzen sehr stark waren, die Krämpfe.
Jetzt haben Sie auch Überkeit?
Jetzt nicht, jetzt nicht Schmerzen, etwas besser,
jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, das habe ich schon, aber längere Zeit,
bei mir ist auch die Prostate vergrößert.
Da habe ich seit ein paar Jahren schon,
muss ich häufiger Wasser lassen und auch nachts raus.
Seit wann haben Sie Prostate Probleme?
Also, festgestellt worden ist es vor fünf Jahren,
beim Urolobe, hat die Prostate aber vergrößert,
aber ich habe es schon seit ein paar Jahren,
vor fünf Jahren, beim Urolobe,
hat die Prostate aber vergrößert, aber ich habe es
gesagt, ich muss halt nachts auf Toilette gehen.
Wie viel mal?
Zwei Mal, manchmal einmal.
Zwei Mal, okay.
Wir haben Medikamente aufgeschrieben dafür.
Ach so, okay.
Wie wurde das behandelt, operativ, oder...
Hat Medikamente mir verschrieben?
Medikamente, okay.
Prostata-Tablette jeden Tag ein.
Welche Tabletten?
Die heißt Duodat.
Duodat.
Okay. Wie viele Milligramm und wie viel Mal? Einmal, oder?
Einmal, aber ich habe jetzt die Packung nicht dabei, Frau Doktor.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele Milligramm es ist.
Okay.
Ja, dann können wir nochmal darüber sprechen, oder?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also, seit gestern, wo ich Schmerzen habe, ist der weniger, aber sonst habe ich ganz guten Appetit, eigentlich.
Und haben Sie Gewichtveränderung bemerkt?
Nein, ich mag nicht. Nein? Okay.
Und haben Sie Schlafstoringen ein oder durch Schlafstoringen?
Nein, ich habe es nicht. Nur jetzt seit gestern vielleicht wegen Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Husten, Atemnot oder Herzrasen?
Also Herzrasen habe ich schon mal gehabt, deswegen habe ich auch Medikamente, aber jetzt aktuell habe ich da jetzt keine Schwierigkeiten mit Herzrasen.
Wann und warum hatten Sie Herzrasen?
Da ist mal so Rhythmostörungs festgestellt worden bei mir, deswegen habe ich die Tabletten bekommen.
Rhythmostörungen, oder?
Ja, so vor zwei, drei Jahren ist das festgestellt worden.
Ich habe Medikamente ein.
Welche Medikamente?
Die Rhythmostörung heißt Konkur.
Konkur? Ja.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Das sind 2,5, das lasse ich mir mal aufschreiben vom Hausarzt, da nehme ich morgen zum Abend eine Tablette.
2,5 Milligramm, oder?
Ja, richtig, ja.
Aber ich nehme andere Medikamente ein. Wollen Sie die Medikamente aufschreiben, die ich einnehme?
Ja, natürlich, das ist wichtige Information.
Also ich nehme noch Blutdruckmedikamente ein?
Blutdruckdruck, oder?
Ja, richtig, ja.
Dann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Oh, auch so, vielleicht so seit fünf, sechs Jahren nehme ich Medikamente ein, glaube ich.
Welche Medikamente?
Candesatan.
Candesatan, okay.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Das sind 16 Milligramm, nehme ich einen morgens.
Sorry, 16 Milligramm, ja.
Okay.
Also hatte ich vor etwa 15 Jahren mal so einen kleinen Schlaganfall, haben die Ärzte festgestellt damals.
Deswegen nehme ich noch ein paar andere Medikamente ein, AHS 100.
Sollte ich auch einen Cholesterinsenker nehmen, den nehme ich abends.
AHS 1 mal?
Einmal, ja.
Und Candesatan auch einmal?
Auch einmal, ja.
Okay, Apoplexy seit vor... vor wann?
Ungefähr 15 Jahren, da war ich mal im Kopf raus, aber das ist dann alles wieder zurückgegangen,
deswegen nehme ich auch ein Cholesterinsenker, also Atorbastatin.
Okay, Moment.
Und erhöhte Cholesterin seit wann haben Sie?
Also mein Cholesterinwert war nicht hoch, aber die haben mir empfohlen, dass ich das einnehme.
Ach so, seit Apoplexy, am Anfang, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Und dann nehme ich noch so ein Blutverdünner ein, der heißt Eliquiz.
Sorry, Atorbastatin wie viel Milligramm?
20 Milligramm, abends eine Tablette.
Und wann ist noch, ja?
Eliquiz, 2,5 Milligramm nehme ich ein, morgens und abends eine.
Eliquiz 2,5 Milligramm.
Abends und morgens.
Richtig, genau.
Dann habe ich gegen meine Gicht, ich hatte auch mal Gicht gehabt, nehme ich auch Medikament ein,
das heißt Alloporinol 300.
Und seit wann haben Sie Gicht?
Oh, das ist schon lange her, weil ich auch da, bestimmt 10, 20 Jahre hatte ich mal Gicht gehabt.
20, 20 Jahren, oder?
Etwa, ja, ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, und dagegen, Gichte ein, weil, nehmen Sie einen?
Alloporinol hat mir der Astlam, das habe ich jemals, nämlich seitdem immer einen.
Alloporinol, wie viel Milligramm?
300 Milligramm, nehme ich abends immer ein.
Entschuldigung, ich kann mich nicht hören.
300 Milligramm, abends einen.
Okay, abends.
Richtig, abends.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Eisentablette, die der Haushalt mir versprochen hat, da hatte ich gesagt, ich hatte ein bisschen Eisenmangel.
Und dann ist deswegen nämlich morgens abends eine Eisentablette, Pherosanol.
Pherosanol.
Und da hat er mir aber auch schon gesagt, der Haushalt, dass das manchmal so Bauchschmerzen machen kann.
Deswegen dachte ich, vielleicht, dass es vielleicht vom Eisentablette kommt.
Und Pherosanol, wie viel Milligramm?
100 Milligramm, nehme ich auch 2 mal eine Tablette.
2 mal.
Und das waren meine Medikamente, meine Liste nach.
Okay, nun muss ich alles.
Was ich beruflich habe, habe ich gesagt, glaube ich, dass ich das genommen habe.
Ja, ja, Beinbedarf, oder?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, und seit wann haben Sie Eisenmangel?
Das hat der Haushalt beim Bluttest festgestellt.
Das war vor einem halben Jahr oder im Jahr, ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, seit sechs Monaten, oder?
Ungefähr, ja.
Ungefähr, okay.
Und gibt es noch etwas?
Nee, das waren alle Medikamente jetzt, glaube ich.
Okay, ja, Sie nehmen zu viele Medikamente ein.
Ja, leider ja.
Ja, das kann sehr schwer sein.
Ja, ich nehme mich.
Ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie leiden unter Rhythmische Tourungen.
Alter, sorry, Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Und vor 15 Jahren Schlaganfall.
Richtig.
Und erhöhte Lipid, Blutfettwerte.
Nee, das weiß ich nicht, das haben wir, haben Sie gefragt.
Achso, sorry, ja, ja, ich erinnere mich, sorry.
Ja, wegen des Schlaganfalls, wenn Sie es sehen.
Ja, genau.
Richtig.
Okay, okay.
Und seit 20 Jahren Gicht.
Ja, so seitdem nehme ich Medikamente ein, ja.
Ja, ja.
Und seit sechs Monaten Anime.
Eisenmangel.
Eisenmangel, richtig, genau.
Eisenmangel, ja.
Ja, das ist wichtig, wichtige Information.
Deswegen muss ich alles notieren.
Ja.
Und hatten Sie irgendwelche Operationen?
Also, als Jugendlicher ist Blinde einmal operiert worden,
aber ansonsten keine Operation.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Also, war ich so 14 Jahre alt, glaube ich.
14 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Keine Allergien bekannte.
Okay.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Das weiß ich nicht, ich glaube.
Gegen Kinderkirchigkeiten und Corona und Tethanus?
Corona, ja, Tethanus.
Der Haus hat mal überprüft gehabt, aber ich weiß nicht genau,
ob da was fehlt.
Aber Corona hat alle Impfungen.
Okay, ich glaube, Sie haben Impfpass.
Muss ich von Hause aus mitbringen?
Ich habe nicht dabei.
Ja, ja, okay.
Kein Problem, wenn Sie brauchen, können wir mit dem Hausarzt kontaktieren.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Und treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, ich bin nur noch befreundlich.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also, nicht regelmäßig manchmal zum Essen, ein Bier, aber auch nicht jeden Tag.
Wie viel Mal pro Woche?
3-4 Mal vielleicht.
3-4 Mal.
Ein Flasche Bier, oder?
Ja, mehr nicht.
Und rauchen Sie?
Ja, nicht mehr.
Ich habe aufgehört vor 15 Jahren.
Und wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Also, als ich aufgehört habe, war ich so ungefähr knapp 60,
so neun, 50 Jahre alt, und habe mit 20 angefangen.
Also, bestimmt habe ich 40 Jahre geraucht, aber nicht viel.
Ich habe maximal ein halbes Päckchen Zigaretten geraucht.
40 Jahre und halben Schattel pro Tag.
Richtig, ja.
Mehr war es nicht.
Und nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen ein?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich keinen ein.
Okay, super.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Rentner.
Ich war Feuerbeamter in der Stadt im Ordnungsamt.
Okay.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe 2 Kinder, aber sind schon erwachsen.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Sind Ihre Kinder?
Ja, so weit keine größeren Krankheiten.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Und leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, wir leben zusammen.
Und gibt es irgendwelche wichtige Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie?
Ich meine Ihre Mutter, Ihr Vater oder Geschwister?
Also, Eltern sind schon beide gestorben.
Ja, der Vater hatte Schlaganfall gehabt, ist dann gestorben.
Ich hatte 2 weitere Geschwister.
Die sind beide jünger als ich.
Der eine, wo da auch Probleme mit Herz- und Bluthochdruck.
Und die Schwester hat auch mit Rheuma zu tun und Zuckerkrankheit.
Schwester, sorry.
Ich habe eine kleine Schwester, die ich mit der Mutter hatte.
Ich hatte keine Schwester, die ich mit der Mutter hatte.
Aber Schwester, sorry.
Ich konnte nicht erst der Krankheiten...
Ja, mit Rheuma.
Und hat Zuckerkrankheit auch.
Aber ist es nicht schwer krank, die ist sonst ganz gesund.
Ja, super, Gott sei Dank.
Herr Schülig, sind meine Frage festweilt?
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Eigentlich, da haben Sie das wichtigste gefragt, Frau Doktor.
Und ja, ich hoffe, dass Sie mir jetzt helfen können,
dass die Schmerzen besser werden.
Und vielleicht auch ein paar Entgeben gegen Schmerzen.
Ja, ja.
Ich werde Sie so erst körperlicher untersuchen.
Und dann ein paar Dabo-Untersuchungen verlassen.
Dann werde ich mit meinem Chef aus darüber gesprochen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen Bescheid geben, um Sie auch dem Lauf an das zu halten.
Alles klar. Frau Doktor, ich bin privat versichert.
Ich weiß nicht, haben Sie ein Einzelzimmer für mich?
Das ist immer für mich leichter, wenn ich nicht jemandem in meinem Zimmer liegen muss.
Ja, ich bin privat versichert.
Okay, aber so erst muss ich kontrollieren, ob es Freisimmer gibt.
Alles klar, okay.
Ich glaube, es gibt eine Freisimmer.
Das wäre sehr nett.
Ja, okay, ich kann Ihnen helfen.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Dieses Mediation dauerte ungefähr 24 Minuten.
Okay, ich muss weitersuchen.
Nee, ist gut. 24 Minuten ist okay, glaube ich.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Glaube ich ja.
So, bitte schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Wann war Ihr letztes Stuhl?
Der letzte Stuhl war vor drei Tagen.
Okay, ich.
Zweite Frage ist, hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Magenspiegelung oder
Daranspiegelung gehabt?
Sehr gute Frage, nein.
Hausarzt hat empfohlen, aber er wollte nicht.
Er hatte Angst gehabt.
Okay, das war es.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Schilding.
Ja.
Fühlen Sie sich im Laufe der Zeit Erschöpf oder haben Sie auch
Greterenschmerzen?
Nein.
Also er fühlt sich sonst wie immer, nur dass gestern hat er Schmerzen,
sonst aber war alles okay.
Okay.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Hat Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen?
Ja, es ist ein Abend.
Es ist ein Abend.
Nur die Fernseher diagnostiziert meine Fragen, Herr Schilding.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Mund etwas Wunde bemerkt haben?
Keine Wunden im Mund.
Es gibt auch Augenprobleme.
Augen?
Augenprobleme.
Auch kein Augenproblem, nein.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt, Herr Schilding.
Okay.
Als Sie es gesprochen haben.
Was ist die Vettachzeugnose von Frau Doktor?
Die Anamnese deutet am ehesten hin,
die Anamnese deutet auf die Anamnese.
Als die Fernseherdiagnose kommen,
die Vertikulitis,
und Darmsündungen in Betracht.
Ich werde die Diagnose bestätigen.
Dann stellen Sie vor den Patienten.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberhaus.
Wir haben einen neuen Patienten.
Herr Otto Schilding.
Ich würde Ihnen über ihn berichten.
Ich muss zu den nächsten Patienten gehen.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Ich versuche es nicht zu machen.
Der Patient berichtete.
Wie alt ist der Patient?
Er ist 74 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,88 m groß.
Er ist 98 kg schwer.
Er berichtete, dass er seit gestern Abend
bestehende, zunehmende, krampfartige Bauchsmassen
in Linken Unterbauch.
Vor zwei Jahren hat er Ängliche beschwerten.
Er hat ein paar Tage geschmackt.
Die Schmerzen seien 7-8 von Sen auf einer Skala.
Beim Krampf seien die Schmerzen verschlimmert geworden.
Er hat gestern einmal erbrochen.
Vor einer Woche hatte er Verstopfung.
Er hatte dunkle Brust.
Er hatte eine Schmerz-Geräuschung.
Er hatte einen Blut im Stuhl.
Seit einigen Monaten musste er
unregelmäßig durch Fallmitteils benutzen.
Er hatte seit einigen Monaten unregelmäßige Stuhlgang.
Die Schmerzen haben keine Ausstrahlung.
Er hat gestern und heute Morgen
400 mg eingenommen.
Er hat ein bisschen geholfen.
Er hatte keine Intoleranz und Unverträglichkeit.
Er hatte morgen früh einmal
Subfabrile Temperaturen.
Er hatte Überkeit beim Schmerzen.
Vor drei Tagen hatte er letzte Schuhtul.
Er hatte zwei Mal auf der Toilette geholfen.
Er hatte eine Prostatipopiparplazie.
Er hatte eine Erkrankung.
Er hatte eine Rhythmus-Schutur.
Er hatte sechs Jahre Epopylixie.
Er hatte einen Geist seit sechs Jahren.
Er hatte eine Prostatipopiparplazie.
Ich habe als Medikationen nehme regelmäßig Dudat einmal pro Tag und komme 52 Milligramm
2,5 Milligramm abends und morgens und Kontersatan 16 Milligramm einmal und ASS 100 Milligramm
einmal und Atobastatin 20 Milligramm abends, Elkiwiss 2,5 Milligramm abends und morgens,
Aluprinol 300 Milligramm abends und Ferrosonal Ferrosanol 100 Milligramm abends und morgens ein.
morgens und abends. Mit 14 Jahren wurde er wegen Appanthesitis operiert.
Mit 14 Jahren wurde er operiert.
Mit 14 Jahren wurde er wegen Appanthesitis operiert.
Er trinkt 3-4 Mal provohe eine Flasche Bier und er ist extrahörig. Er rochte 20 Piggy-Parks
und er hat keine Allergie. Er hatte eine Social-Anamnese. Er hatte eine Familien-Anamnese.
Er ist an Apoplexie gestorben und seine Mutter ist an Momakassin gestorben und sein Bruder leidet unter Atelier.
Seine Schwester leidet an Arterialhypertonie und Herzerkrankung.
Seine Schwester leidet an Römer und Diabetes Militus.
Er ist in der Social-Anamnese. Er sieht, dass er in der Rente ist.
Als angestellte Arbeitete er.
Als Beamter hat er gearbeitet.
Als Beamter. Er ist verheiratet. Er hat 2 Kinder und mit seiner Frau zusammengelebt.
Die Anamnese deutet am ehesten auf Kohle-Rectalkarsenoma hin.
Warum?
Er ist 74 Jahre alt. Er hat linke Unterbauchschmerzen und Verstopfung.
Vor 3 Tagen hatte er den letzten Stuhlgang. Er hat viele Vorerkrankungen.
Aber das spricht nicht alles.
Hat er eine Besündermatik oder andere Tumor-adrozierte Symptome?
Die Verdachtdiagnose kann richtig sein.
Aber ich will wissen, warum Sie das als Hauptdiagnose formulieren.
Deswegen frage ich nach diesen B-Symptomen.
Wissen Sie, was B-Symptome sind?
Nein.
Besündermatik ist oft mit Tumor-Assoziert mit Gewichtsverlust.
Mehr als 10 kg pro kg Körpergewicht in 1,5 Jahren.
Fieber, unklare Ursache, Nachtschweiß.
Das waren glaube ich Besundfieber und Nachtschweiß.
Hat er verneint, glaube ich.
Die Besündermatik beweist nicht, dass er keinen Krebs hat.
Aber zumindest ist es kein Hinweis darauf.
Was ist aus der Ananasie eher ein Hinweis?
Dass das koleutale Katzenum eher unwahrscheinlich ist.
Macht ein Kohl- und Katzenum-Schmerzen normalerweise?
Normalerweise sind das Schmerzen los.
Ja.
Es sei denn?
Es gibt eine...
Es sei denn, es ist ein großer, zum Beispiel,
einen Wandüberschreiter T4-Tumor,
die durch Schmerzen verursachen kann.
Richtig?
Ja, wenn es gibt eine Komplikation,
können wir Schmerzhafte beschwerden,
die wir beschreiben.
Und Jan-Ber erzählt,
der hat vor zwei Jahren schon mal die gleichen Beschwerden gehabt.
Ja.
Damals, dass auch schon Krebs gewesen ist.
Er hatte zwei Jahre lang ohne Probleme gelebt.
Wenn damals schon der Krebs so groß gewesen wäre,
dass er Schmerzen gehabt hätte.
Da haben Sie das eher nicht.
Also schließt es nicht aus,
aber aus dieser Ananasieangabe würde ich eher schließen,
dass das kolorektale Katz-Num eher die Differenzialdiagnose ist.
Kann natürlich trotzdem,
dass er vor zwei Jahren ein anderes Problem hat,
aber jetzt Kolorkatz-Num,
aber aufgrund dieser Tatsache würde ich sagen,
dass er rezidivierend Entzündung hat.
Zum Beispiel diese diversifizierte...
Ja, vielleicht die vertikulitis.
Das wäre meine erste Verdachtdiagnose.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe recht, ja.
Gut, aber was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Jetzt haben Sie ihn aufgenommen,
körperlich untersucht.
Was untersuchen Sie körperlich bei den Patienten?
Ja, Abtasten im Bauch und Palpation, natürlich, ja.
Was kann man manchmal tasten bei so einer Divertikulitis?
Manchmal?
Nicht immer, aber kann mal vorkommen,
dass sie etwas tasten auch schon bei der Palpation.
Ich weiß nicht.
Douglas, zum Beispiel.
Sorry?
Douglas, Douglas, Douglas, Douglas, Douglas.
Das wäre ein Serb,
weil ich meine, dass sie von außen die Palpation am Bauch,
das kann sein, dass sie eine Resistenztasten im Unterbauch,
also eine Walze zum Beispiel.
Eine Weckerlöhe und Tänzer.
Gibt es mal, manchmal, ja.
Douglas Schmerz, hat der Doktor schon richtig gesagt,
wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Was untersuchen Sie noch?
Was ist am Bauch wichtig, wenn Sie den Bauch untersuchen?
Was müssen Sie feststellen,
wenn Sie den Abtasten, den Patienten abhören?
Was ist da wichtig?
Ja, Bauch, Darangelusche.
Richtig, genau.
Das ist richtig.
Und Milz und Leberverkursung oder...?
Das ist allgemein, aber bei diesem Patient,
wo Sie den Verdacht auf die Vertikulitis haben,
was ist da wichtig,
damit Sie wissen, ob Sie den Chirurgen holen müssen, zum Beispiel?
Was ist wichtig?
Was müssen Sie ihm sagen?
Sie holen Chirurgen an, sagen Sie, ich habe ein Patient mit die Vertikulitis,
der hat das und das.
Er fragt nach, was hat er?
Wie ist der Untersuchungsbefund?
Was sagen Sie?
Er will wissen, ob der Bauch akut ist, gell?
Wie ist ein Bauch akut?
Oder was tastet oder was untersucht man da beim akuten Bauch?
Wie kann der Bauch...?
Sie eines haben gesagt,
schon, ein Darmgeräusch, wenn die hochgestellt sind, gell?
Was kann das bedeuten, wenn die hochgestellt sind,
die Darmgeräusche?
Wissen Sie, was hochgestellt Darmgeräusche sind?
Hochgestellt?
Ja.
Rollulus oder...?
Oder?
Oder, wenn der Darm zugeht, wie nennt man das?
Wenn der Darm zu ist durch die Entzündung.
Wie nennt man das?
Ilius.
Achso, ich?
Genau, Ilius kann mechanisch,
Ilius kann erhöhte Darmgeräusche machen.
Wie ist der Bauch, wenn der Ilius hat der Patient?
Ist der normalweich oder wie ist der?
Nein, ganz...
Sorry, ich erinnere mich...
keine Bauch.
Der ist gespannt oder hat Abwehrspannung der Bauch?
Abwehrspannung.
Der Bauch ist zum Beispiel, wenn es extrem ist, brett hart.
Also, ist ganz hart.
Ein Zeichen von einer Komplikation sein.
Das will der Schock wissen.
Wenn Sie ihn rufen, fragt er am Telefon,
wie ist der Bauch, ist der weich?
Brett hart, hat Druckschmerz.
Und wie sind die Darmgeräusche?
Das fragt er Sie immer dann, gell?
Das müssen Sie ihm sagen.
Ja.
Gut, jetzt haben Sie den Bauch untersucht,
abgehört, also der Bauch ist weich.
Darmgeräusche sind regelrecht,
alle vier Quadranten nicht hochgestellt.
Kein Duklaerschmerz.
Wie untersuchen Sie den Duklaerschmerz?
Ja, sparmstern oder tief.
Ah, sorry, Druckschmerz haben Sie?
Duklaerschmerz.
Wie untersuchen Sie Duklaerschmerz?
Ich habe alles vergessen.
Macht nichts dafür, Herr Merzier.
Durch eine digitalerektale Untersuchung,
das ist auch wichtig, damit Sie wissen,
ob der Rektum am Polyfreie ist,
ob da Blut am Fingerling ist,
das ist eine wichtige Information,
die Sie erst mal erheben müssen.
Sie haben am Fingerling ein bisschen Stuhl,
aber kein Blut und hat kein Duklaerschmerz der Patient.
Auch gut.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Ja, das.
Was machen Sie beim Patienten?
Blutabnahme,
Beinahe und
Entzündung parameter.
Welche?
CRP
und Blutbild
und
Leukocytose,
genau Blutbeblöcke,
und Stuhltest,
ja Stuhltest.
Ja, machen wir.
Und wenn es möglich.
Und was noch,
Abdomenutroschalk,
sehr.
Abdomen
um die Komplikationen
auszuschließen.
Perfekt, ja.
Das hat viel Luft im Bauch.
Sie können Ultraschalen nicht gut buttern.
Also hat viel Flatulenz,
viel Meteorismus.
Und Ultraschalen ist schwierig.
Was machen Sie dann?
CT.
Ja, Konzentration.
Damit können Sie die Diagnose stellen
oder verwerfen,
ja, genau.
Und wenn Sie den Verdacht auf,
die wir Zuccolitis haben,
genau,
machen Sie auch
andersrum.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt,
das ist ja eine Sache, die Komplikation machen kann.
Welche Komplikationen gibt es bei Diwaticulitis?
Sorry.
Ist das eine Sache,
die
leicht ist
oder schwer,
lebensgefährlich?
Ja, das ist nicht so.
Ja.
Das ist nicht so
schwer und gefährlich.
Aber trotzdem
gibt es schwer Komplikation
wegen des Infektions
anstecken.
Was meinen Sie mit Infektion?
Was kann passieren,
wenn Infektion...
Ich habe das Wort vergessen.
Abszess kann man sich bilden,
ja.
Was kann dann die Komplikation
davon abscessen,
wenn man es nicht behandelt?
Ja,
selbst ist es.
Genau, richtig.
Also Infektion, selbst ist es.
Was gibt es noch für Komplikation?
Gibt es mögliche Komplikation,
mögliche...
Perforation, ja.
Perforation, genau.
Das haben Sie jetzt auch genannt,
kann auch Infektionskomplikation machen.
Dann haben wir eine Sache schon besprochen,
weswegen Sie mit dem Schirm gesprochen haben.
Was kann passieren?
Was kann noch passieren?
Was ist Komplikation?
Hat der Patient auch schon angegeben,
in seiner Anamnese,
nur einmal hat er gesagt,
aber kann natürlich mehr werden.
Was hat er angegeben?
Ja, genau, kann Blutungskomplikation.
Starke Blutung kann man sein.
Also eine untere GI-Blutung.
Komplikation und Infektion,
selbst ist Blutung.
Genau, das werden die wichtigsten,
die mir einfallen, ja.
Und dann gibt es natürlich noch ein paar Spätkomplikationen.
Das ist ja auch so,
dass die vertikuliert ist, in Schüben verleuchtet.
Das ist ja auch bei ihm so gewesen.
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren mal gehabt,
dann kann es sein, dass es wieder von alleine weg geht und so weiter.
Was gibt es für Spätkomplikation?
Wenn es immer wieder auftritt.
Ich weiß nicht, auf Deutsch.
Ja, weg.
Sie haben ja auf Türkisch, wenn Sie nicht wissen.
Ja, die politischen Klubhalle.
Komplikation, da oben.
Briden, meinen Sie, ja?
Briden, also Atherenzen, Briden.
Ja, Atherenzen.
Also Briden, die dann auch zum Ilius führen können, richtig.
Und wenn so chronische Entzündungen bestehen,
um den Sigma herum,
da ist ja auch noch ein paar andere Organe.
Bei Frauen sind da noch Unterleibsorgane,
Blase und so weiter.
Was kann passieren, wenn chronische Entzündungen da immer bestehen?
Kannst du fistern,
wenn du eine andere Organe hast,
dann kannst du es auch nicht mehr.
Das ist ja auch so,
dass man dann auch bei chronischen Verläufen fistern kann.
Manchmal bei chronischen Verläufen.
Fistel zum Beispiel.
Ja, fistern.
Wenn sie kalt fistern,
oder bei Frauen dann rekt,
also vaginale fistern,
zum Beispiel im Extremfall.
Aber das sind dann eher so seltene Sachen.
Gut, wie behandeln Sie jetzt den Patienten?
Das haben Sie CT gemacht, man sieht,
keine Perforation
oder maximal ein bisschen Physik drum herum.
Wie behandeln Sie
den würden Sie jetzt nicht operieren vermutlich,
wenn er jetzt keinen akuten Bauch hat?
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Ja, so.
Gegengebeinfalls wird ein Patient operiert.
Bei dem muss man es nicht operieren.
Der hat jetzt keine hohen Entzündungswerte,
hat keinen akuten Bauch
und keine Komplikation.
Muss man nicht.
Kann man konservativ machen?
Ja, mit Medikamenten
mit Medikamenten
mit dem,
mit dem Medikament ist behandelt.
Welche Medikamente?
Welche gibt man da?
Also, Schmerzmedikamente, klar,
aber was machen Sie?
Schmerztherapie
und Antibiotiktherapie
und natürlich, ja.
Und dann
die etische Therapie auch
richtig.
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Ja, dann gegebenenfalls wird
den Patienten operiert.
Genau, wenn man später in den Verlauf
das sich angucken kann.
Ja.
Gut, und wenn er immer wieder
diese Probleme hat,
Sie haben ja schon gedacht, die etätische Maßnahmen,
empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Die etätisch.
Ja, viel
Flüssigkeit
und weniger
Fleisch
und
Fleischarm
Ernährung
Obst und Gemüse
und
Verstopfung
zu vermeiden.
Ja, achten
muss er
oft die etät achten.
Genau, was sind zwei Obst und Gemüse?
Was ist das Hauptmerkmal
dieser Obst und Gemüse Ernährung?
Wie nennt man das?
Das sind Sachen, die im Körper nicht resoriert werden.
Wie nennt man diese
Diätern oder diese
kostbarlaststoffreich
und faserreiche Ernährung?
Ja, genau.
Alles klar, sehr gut, ja.
Prima.
Ich habe diese Patientleiter
seit 2, 3 Jahren
an einem mehr.
Warum wurde diese Patient nicht
korrekt unter
Ja, Hausarzt hat gesagt,
die Patientin macht dann ab 50,
hat Angst, der will nicht.
Seit 6 Monaten hat er
Panemie.
Kann, dass er chronischen Blutverlust hat.
Aber, was sie gesagt haben, ist immer wichtig,
also
diese Diagnose nicht immer ab,
sondern die Vertequenzen, sie müssen immer gucken.
Das kann immer trotzdem an den Kohl- und Katzen um dahinter verbergen.
Deswegen
nicht allein mit der Diagnose
die Vertequenzen zufrieden geben,
sondern auch immer, wie Sie schon gesagt haben,
die Diagnose kann nur um abklären.
Das kann es nur für das.
Wichtig, ja.
Ich finde, da wäre die Verdachtsdiagnose
nicht ganz so unwichtig.
Aber in dem Fall, dass ich sage,
das ist die zweite Option,
erste Option war siegend, die Vertequenzen.
Ja.
Okay.
Morgen.
Qualitisch und seröser,
differenzial Diagnostisch können wir
sagen, oder nicht?
Ja.
Qualitisch und seröser sagen?
Aber der Allgemein Qualitisch, klar.
Kann ja auch mal andere Rosa haben.
Aber er hat keine,
was durchfallt der Rös.
Doch, hat er gesagt,
er hat ja Stuhlunregelmäßigkeiten.
Das kann schon sein,
das ist eine milde Form der Qualitis auch sein kann.
Das ist schon nirgendwo.
Oder was natürlich noch,
noch, sag ich mal weniger ist,
dass er nicht mehr auf dem Stuhl verhält.
Ja.
Weg sender, Stuhl verhält.
Das ist richtig, Roger.
Ja, beziehungsweise
Stuhlverhält, ich bin dann,
ja, kann man sagen, also
Weg sender, Obzipation
oder insgesamt Stuhlunregelmäßigkeiten.
Er hat ja auch Durchfall gehabt,
hat er gesagt, also manchmal Durchfall,
manchmal Verstopfung, also ich bin
unregelmäßige Stuhlverhalten
beschreiben.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
zweimal am Tag
Nacht auf der Zeit
müssen,
was können wir schreiben,
Nikturi?
Ja, Nikturi, ja.
Und einmal
Blut bemerkt,
Hematocesia
oder Blut im Stuhl reicht mir auch.
Und der Patient
hat gesagt,
ich habe Rhythmischutronung
wir können
Atrerfibriation nennen
oder?
Hab ich ja aufgeschrieben, als der Gnose war
Vorflimmern gewesen, aber er wusste nicht mehr genau.
Vorflimmern, ja.
Und
Atritis yurka, Gist.
Hat immer Gistanfall gehabt, ja.
Ich erinnere mich nicht,
deswegen habe ich Gist geschrieben.
Ja, Sie haben Gist geschrieben,
ja, das stimmt auch.
Hat vor 20 Jahren mal Gistanfall gehabt
und seitdem nimmt er Ofylaktichaloporinol ein.
Ja.
Aber war auch
viel Begleiterkrankungen
und viele Begleitmedikamente.
Das haben Sie in der Zeit auch ganz gut gemacht, glaube ich.
Ich habe gesagt,
Hyperlipidemia,
wir haben gesagt,
Hyperlipidemia.
Hyperplasie,
Hyperlipidemia, Hypertonia.
Richtig, richtig, ja.
Hyper, nicht Hyper, ich habe immer.
Romatoitis,
Arthritis,
können Sie sagen,
Romatoid Arthritis, ja.
Romatoid Arthritis, okay.
Abbekürzt mit R, A, oft.
Okay.
Und so können wir beim Arztgespräch
Verkursungen benutzen
oder nein, glaube ich.
Ja.
Ich würde
das
möglichst vermeiden mit Abkürzungen.
Ja, beim
Berief, ja, so für mich, ja.
Beim Arztgespräch würde ich
können Sie machen, aber besser,
wenn Sie es aussprechen, ja.
Ja, okay.